bist du schon da ich habe mich
eigentlich gerade gesandt okay dann
herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt heute
gibt es drei leckere Eisrezepte für euch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir machen heute einen Wassermelone ein
Fruchteis am stehen mit knackiger
Schokolade und ein Cookie Sandwich Eis
mit Lotus richtig richtig lecker und ich
starte jetzt direkt mit dem Wassermelone
sorry dafür braucht ihr eine halbe
Wassermelone 100 g Erdbeeren die können
gefroren sein oder auch frisch zwei
Esslöffel Zucker eine Limette davon
brauche ich den Abrieb und den Saft und
etwas Vanilleextrakt
theoretisch könnt ihr jetzt hergehen und
die Wassermelone direkt in der
Wassermelone pürieren dafür nehmen die
einfach den Pürierstab seid aber ganz
vorsichtig und
los geht's
macht aber gerne ein bisschen Sauerei
falls ihr den Stabmixer nicht so tief
eintaucht
und wenn ihr auf Nummer sicher gehen
wollt hüllt ihr die Wassermelone aus und
püriert dann einfach in dem Glas würde
auch funktionieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
womit ihr euch auch helfen könnt wäre
der Walker
damit so ein bisschen vorher aber ihr
seht schon es läuft ein bisschen anders
[Musik]
darin könnte das jetzt etwas besser
pürieren
[Musik]
hier ist natürlich am besten in dem
Wassermelone ohne Kerne ihr kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich die ganz großen
Wassermelone die haben große Kerne die
eignet sich jetzt nicht so gut denn dann
würdet ihr die Kerne mit pürieren
deswegen nehme ich immer ganz gerne hier
die Kleinen jetzt kommen noch die
Erdbeeren dazu die sorgen zum einen
dafür dass der Geschmack etwas
intensiviert wird und natürlich auch
dafür dass die rote Farbe so ein
bisschen versteckt wird
braucht ihr auch etwas Zucker dann kurz
pürieren
[Musik]
ja mach jetzt auch eine größere Schüssel
nehmen können
aber nur halb so lustig
[Musik]
jetzt noch ein bisschen
dann Limetten Abrieb und etwas Saft dann
ist der Geschmack richtig gut
[Musik]
alles gut gegangen
und jetzt nehmt ihr euch entweder eure
ausgehöhlte Wassermelone füllt das ganze
hier rein und friert ein falls ihr nicht
so viel Platz habt für so eine große
Wassermelone könnt ihr auch ein
flacheres Gefäß nehmen ich nehme auch
ganz gerne weil die die Temperatur
einfach sofort leiten das heißt darin
gefriert es auch einfach schneller also
das ist auch so ein zeitspartipp das
heißt ich will die Masse jetzt hier ein
friere das ganze dann ein und dann werde
ich immer mal zu alle zwei drei Stunden
mit dem wacker so ein bisschen
durchrühren um die eisstruktur zu
zerstören ihr könnt es aber auch einfach
über Nacht einfrieren und später mit
Löffel oder halt auch mit Waka so ein
bisschen zerkratzen und dann ist euer
Sorbet fertig
[Musik]
das Wassermelonen sowie ist fertig ich
kann es jetzt hier direkt servieren und
wir probieren es auch direkt heute ist
Eugen da zum Probieren Eugen kommen wir
probieren
was ist eigentlich herzlich
lecker und ich muss auch sagen ich habe
es nochmal probieren Erdbeeren drin ja
stimmt ich habe probiert Erdbeeren drin
Limette und eigentlich nur ein Esslöffel
Zucker
eigentlich kannst du da die Wassermelone
so wie sie ist abdecken ins Gefrierfach
stellen und für deine Geburtstagsparty
am Wochenende weg
ausprobieren oder zu Hause auf jeden
Fall die passende Schütze hast du ja
schon genau
perfekt für den Sommer okay Eugen nimmt
das wassermeloneneis mit und ich zeige
euch jetzt direkt das zweite Eis das
wird ein Eis am Stiel und ich muss sagen
setzt das Eis im Stehen wird relativ
gesund mit wenig Zucker aber richtig
lecker dafür nehme ich jeweils 200 g
Blaubeeren und Himbeeren 120 Gramm
Banane 200g oder Joghurt etwas Tonka
Paste und zum Süßen gerne 70 Gramm
Agavendicksaft ihr könnt jetzt hier
natürlich selbst entscheiden welche
Früchte ihr nehmt ich nehme jetzt
einfach Heidelbeeren und Himbeeren weil
sie geschmacklich super passen süß das
ganze mit Banane auch ein bisschen nach
und gebe noch ein bisschen
Agavendicksaft dazu müsst ihr nicht
machen ihr könnt auch nur die Süße aus
Früchten verwenden und entweder Joghurt
oder Skier weil es einfach ein bisschen
cremiger ist und Skier hat bisschen mehr
Proteinanteil etwas weniger Fett also
ich finde es ist schon so ein sehr
gesundes Eis wenn man Agavendicksaft
weglässt Zucker noch etwas gesünder aber
ich will ja auch das ist gut schmeckt
und jetzt nicht so viel Banane dazugeben
ihr könnt jetzt frische oder gefrorene
Früchte nehmen ganz wie es euer Mixer
eben auch schafft ihr püriert jetzt
einfach die Früchte miteinander dann
kommen die restlichen Zutaten dazu und
alles wird gut durch
[Musik]
und dann könnt ihr euch diese
Silikonförmchen für Eis nehmen da kommen
diese kleinen holzställe rein und könnt
einfach die Eismasse einfüllen und
einfrieren falls ihr sowas nicht habt
könnt ihr auch Eiswürfelbehälter nehmen
dann könnt ihr so Eiskonfekt machen ihr
könnt aber auch eine große Kastenform
mit Frischhaltefolie auslegen die Masse
rein füllen und am Ende einfach
runterschneiden das geht natürlich auch
theoretisch wenn ihr aber auch gefrorene
Früchte nehmt habt ihr hier praktisch
schon ein fertiges Eis was ihr so direkt
Löffeln können
[Musik]
perfekt dann friere ich die kurz ein und
überziehe dann mit Kuvertüre
das heben wir als es gefroren und jetzt
wäre es eigentlich fertig ihr könnt aber
gerne noch mit Schokolade überziehen das
mache ich jetzt denn ich will einfach
ein richtig leckeres Eis mit
Schokoladenüberzug ihr könnt euch jetzt
für eine schokosorte entscheiden ich
nehme Zartbitter weil da auch muss ich
sagen der Zuckeranteil recht gering ist
so auf ganz natürliche Art und Weise ich
mag Zartbitterschokolade sehr gerne und
falls ihr so ein bisschen darauf achtet
wie viel ihr von essen wollt und den
Zucker reduzieren wollt dann auf jeden
Fall Zartbitterschokolade aber weiß wird
hier auch richtig gut dazu passen also
ich habe jetzt hier meine
Zartbitterkuvertüre ich nehme da jetzt
ungefähr 600g etwas Kokosfett und zum
Dekorieren noch gefriergetrocknete
Himbeeren müsst ihr nicht könnt ihr aber
nehmen
gibt jetzt zwei Drittel davon über ein
Wasserbad und schmelzt es schon mal
schön das Wasser darf nicht mehr kochen
und sobald die Kuvertüre geschmolzen ist
nehmt ihr diese zwei Drittel runter
und rührt einfach noch das restliche
Drittel dazu so kühlt ihr die Kuvertüre
direkt runter und sie hat dann später
einen schönen Glanz ohne eben diesen
stumpfen matt Überzug zu bekommen
also dazu geben wir impfen sozusagen die
Schokolade
und dann kommt auch direkt noch Kokosöl
dazu und das sorgt dafür dass die
Schokolade so ein bisschen flüssiger
wird weil einfach nur ein bisschen Fett
dazu kommt noch ein schöneren Glanz
bekommt und dass sie später einfach so
einen weicheren Bruch hat also man kann
das Eis dann damit so ein bisschen
dünner überziehen
jetzt einfach kurz verrühren und dann
nur noch ganz kurz für 12 Sekunden aufs
warme Wasserbad stellen dann ist die
Kuvertüre perfekt
ich habe jetzt hier einfach zwei
Kühlpads aus dem Gefrierfach und ein
Blech was auch ins Gefrierfach passt
hier ist mein Eis das kann ich jetzt
hier schön rauslösen
[Musik]
mit dem Eis hier drunter verschafft ihr
euch einfach ein bisschen Zeit denn wenn
es bei euch in der Küche sehr warm ist
schmilzt das Eis natürlich recht schnell
und so habt ihr einfach eine schöne
kühle Fläche und habt einfach ein
bisschen Zeit zum Arbeiten okay jetzt
nehmt ihr euch am besten ein Glas dafür
füllt ihr die Kuvertüre ein
das Glas könnt ihr vorher gerne so ein
bisschen erwärmen oder einfach immer mal
ins Wasser stellen denn durch das Eis
wird die Schokolade jetzt relativ
schnell fest
und jetzt im Prinzip eigentlich nur
eintauchen kurz abtropfen lassen und
hier drauflegen
[Musik]
und schon seid ihr fertig die packe ich
jetzt noch mal ins Gefrierfach und
theoretisch könnt ihr sie dann wenn sie
noch mal schön durchgefroren sind
einfach auch verpacken und wirklich für
mehrere Wochen im Gefrierfach Lagern
wird nicht passieren dann bei uns werden
Sie gleich gegessen
ich finde das Eis richtig richtig schön
und dafür dass es selbstgemacht ist
finde ich sieht auch richtig perfekt aus
und Eis am Stiel kann man ganz einfach
selbst machen ich würde sagen wir
probieren das jetzt
Alexa danke schön aus ich finde nämlich
das Innere vom Eis passt perfekt zu
deinem bin ich mal gespannt was drin ist
probier mal
ich hatte eben schon Angst
ich habe schon ich habe schon heimlich
probiert
muss auch sagen ich bin
Zartbitterschokolade ich auch ich habe
kurz überlegt ob ich weiß Schokolade
mache aber ich fand bitte ich mag sehr
gut aber das stimmt farblich passt ja
perfekt sehr sehr lecker und da könnt
ihr wirklich entscheiden je nachdem was
für Früchte ihr da habt welches Obst
kann mir Geschmack zu machen wenn man
will das stimmt
richtig einfach also das war Rezept Idee
Nummer zwei und jetzt kommt Rezeptidee
Nummer 3 und die ist wirklich ganz
einfach noch einfacher als dieses Eis
sogar
dafür nehmt ihr einfach ein Eis eurer
Wahl ich habe jetzt hier einen
Vanilleeis Schoko Kekse mit weißem
Schokoladenstückchen hier etwas
lotuscreme das ist die cremige Variante
und Lotus Kekse okay das ist jetzt
wirklich einfach aber es ist glaube ich
eine richtig coole Idee für alle die den
coolen eissnack machen wollen der
einfach etwas cooler ist als einfach nur
eine Kugel Eis mit Lotus Streuseln drauf
deswegen nimmt jetzt einfach die Kekse
einen Eisportionierer eine Kugel
Vanilleeis
und packt die dann hier dazwischen
und jetzt macht ihr ein Sandwich draus
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe nur ein Eis Sandwiches gedacht
ich schwöre
ganz schnell verstehst Bilder machen
warum
Vanilleeis
Sandwich
Entschuldigung
vor und dann kommen sie einfach ins
Gefrierfach okay
jedenfalls kommen die eissandwiche jetzt
ins Gefrierfach die müssen jetzt nämlich
noch mal gut gefrieren und dann werde
ich die lotuscreme in der Mikrowelle
oder einfach über dem warmen Wasser
warten bisschen schmelzen die
eissandwiches dann eintauchen bis zur
Hälfte und die zerbröselten lotuskekse
einfach nur drüber geben und dann
schnell wieder einfrieren und sobald das
Sandwich als dann gefroren ist könnt ihr
es direkt probieren und ich würde sagen
ich nehme die beste eisverkäuferin der
Welt mit dazu aus dem Keller ja okay
das haben unser Gefrierfach ist ein
bisschen überfordert heute mit so viel
Eis
en Wackelzahn verliert
[Musik]
und wie findest du es super Idee
und vor allem schnell gemacht aber ich
würde sagen das was man mit Eis eins und
zwei gut macht an zuckerreduktion wollen
wir bei 13 natürlich alles wieder rein
weil das ist schon muss ich sagen das
haut rein zwei Kekse Vanilleeis plus
Lotus plus Lotus Kekse aber man kann
sich ja sonst nichts außerdem ist es und
bleibt es eine Süßigkeit gell
also probiert es gerne aus ich habe hier
drei Eisrezepte für euch bzw drei Eis
Ideen und ihr könnt ja mal gerne
schreiben welche Variante ausprobieren
werdet und falls ihr noch Wünsche habt
dann schreibt sie auch gerne in die
Kommentare und weitere Eis Rezepte
findet ihr wie immer in meiner App viel
Spaß beim nachmachen
[Musik]